i'm looking up in canada right now
canada has
essentially declared a public health
regime that will suspend
all political rights that in any way
contradict
the capricious and whims of the experts
we have implemented the strictest
measures
in all of north america and the
difficult truth is
every public health measure we have left
comes with a massive cost to people
in their lives but we have never shied
away
from doing what's necessary we have made
the deliberate decision
to temporarily enhance police officers
authority for the duration of the
stay-at-home order
moving forward police will have the
authority to require
any individual who is not in a place of
resonance
to first provide their purpose for not
being at home
and provide their home address police
will also have the authority to stop a
vehicle
to inquire about an individual's reason
for leaving their residence
and our inspectors will also be ensuring
that those who absolutely must come to
work
are strictly following the public health
measures
for our employers and employees take
note
this is your last warning
this is the vision of the future
eggheads
sitting in ill-fitting suits
with their glasses on perfectly straight
face
saying hey listen society this is your
last warning
stay imprisoned in your home or we will
arrest you
because of the cough that we said was
only going to
be a worry for two weeks a year ago
if you do not comply with our every whim
your life will be ruined and your
your political order has already been
ruined because we now run the show
you think that can't happen here
this is it requires such a failure of
imagination
it requires such an ignorance of of not
just ancient history but really the last
12 months to believe
that what's going on in canada right now
cannot or even
likely will not come to the united
states
every political measure that we have
been
promised two weeks to slow the spread
just gotta flatten that curve
oh just got to find the cure every
single promise
that these people have made to us they
have broken
every timeline they have given us
has failed it has
only gotten more intense more
draconian looking around at the
anglo-saxon peoples
you know england
australia new zealand canada united
states
look look what our friends around the
anglosphere are doing
you don't think that's going to come
here the only way it doesn't come here
is if we fight back very hard if we
exert
all the political leverage that we have
it's already coming here it's all it's
actually already coming here wait wait
wait wait wait don't nope
nope do not not yet you can't go
until you smash that subscribe button
you hit that
like button you gotta do it okay or for
other channels
it's totally cool youtube they love
those channels they promote them all the
time
for us maybe they don't like exactly
what we're saying so head on over
make sure you subscribe and never miss a
video
[Music]
[Music]